there was one moment though that was
really disturbing which is
uh some woman stands up and says that
her little children are transgender
and wants to know joe biden's thoughts
on transiting little kids
and he he gave the wrong answer i'm the
proud mom
of two girls eight and ten
my youngest daughter is transgender she
isn't
she is she isn't a she i mean if she's
saying if this woman is saying that her
youngest daughter is transgender what
she's saying is she has a little
eight-year-old boy
and she's pretending that that little
eight-year-old boy is a girl but the
little boy isn't a girl
the little boy is a boy barely capable
of reason
at age eight well below the age of
consent ten years below the age of
consent
and this woman is an abusive mother
who's damaging her little son
and i don't know why she's doing that
but it is truly
truly awful and if there is ever a role
for the state to get involved it's when
parents are abusing their little boys
and trying to pretend that they're
little girls for whatever
psychotic reason has motivated them to
do that in their own
adult heads obviously not very
well-formed adult heads
this is some sick stuff now probably by
the way the state would come in
with child protective services and take
your kids away from you if you don't
trans the kids if you don't let your
little boy who says he's a girl dress up
like a little girl
but of course in a just society the
opposite would be true so she she poses
this question she goes
what should i look i want to dress my
little boy up as a girl and have him
pretend to be a little girl
what are you going to do about that when
people say that that's not such a nice
thing
joe biden says you know i'm sorry you're
going through that
absolutely we should trans the kids how
will you as president reverse
this dangerous and discriminatory agenda
and ensure that the lives and rights of
lgbtq people are protected
under u.s law i will flat out just
change the law
every eliminate those executive orders
number one
there should be zero discrimination
and what's happening is too many
transgender
women of color are being murdered
they're being murdered
there is no reason to suggest
that there should be any right denied
your daughter or daughters whichever
one or two one one your daughter that
your other daughter has a right to be
and do
none zero so you can tell joe biden
doesn't know anything about this issue
so he just goes back to the one talking
point that some staffer told him which
is
transgender women of color are being
murdered now
i know when you say that it sounds like
there's some epidemic of this in the
country but it's not the case it's
something like
20 per year 20 black men who are who
identify as women and usually when you
look into the individual cases it's
because
they're involved in prostitution or
something like that and are
are killed by black men who are either
didn't know that they were transgender
who knows i mean these are very very sad
cases but
they're very particular cases all right
this is not like milli this is happening
to millions of people per year or
anything like that but obviously it
doesn't affect this woman
she is very much a white woman and her
daughters or you know her son and her
daughter are not adults
this is this is not about whether adults
can choose to dress a certain way or
identify a certain way
this is about whether eight-year-old
children can be made to
look more like the opposite sex whether
you can block their puberty whether you
can shoot them full of hormones
whether you can castrate them whether
you can cross-dress them
this is some sick perverted stuff and
any reasonable society would stand up
and say listen lady i don't know what
you're doing to your kid
but stop dressing your little boy up
like a little girl when he gets older
when he if he's 25 years old and he
decides he wants to put on a dress at
night
that's his own business but you sure
shouldn't be doing that can you imagine
how confusing that is to a little boy
when i was eight years old i wore a
little batman cape around birthday
parties
and told people to call me batman i'm
very pleased my mother did not indulge
the fantasy that
i wish you had indulged the fantasy that
i was a billionaire that would have been
great i would
actually okay maybe i'm undercutting my
own argument but certainly if i thought
i was a different sex
that can be extraordinarily damaging i
hope you enjoyed that short segment from
the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you